liebe kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
willkommen an sie alle in der
bundespressekonferenz ich würde langsam
auch die fotografinnen und fotografen
bitten
hier vorne etwas das fans rein
und ich beginne einfach schon mal mit
ein paar einleitenden worten als erstes
möchte ich ihnen natürlich unsere gäste
vorstellen
bundesgesundheitsminister professor karl
lauterbach zu meiner rechten ich gehe
die reihenfolge durch professor dr lars
schaade der vizepräsident des robert
koch-instituts heute dabei und zum
ersten mal soweit ich das weiß an dieser
stelle hier in der bundespressekonferenz
professor dr michael meyer hermann von
helmholtz zentrum für
infektionsforschung in braunschweig er
leitet dort die abteilung system
immunologie
wie immer sprechen wir in dieser
pressekonferenz über die aktuelle
politische lage da die live übertragen
werden möchte ich noch kurz ein paar
worte zu unserer institution sagen die
bundespressekonferenz ist eine
selbstorganisation von journalisten
journalisten die bundespolitik berichten
wir veranstalten hier pressekonferenzen
laden gäste zu uns ein die uns rede und
antwort stehen wir sind also
regierungsunabhängig wir begrenzen diese
pressekonferenz heute sehr streng auf
eine stunde weil es gleich im anschluss
mit einer weiteren pressekonferenz
weiter geht und deswegen werde ich auch
ziemlich streng auf die regel achten
eine frage mit der möglichkeit einer
nachfrage pro person so viel der vorrede
und wir beginnen herr lauterbach bitte
sein vielen dank frau war für ihre
großzügige einladung dass wir vortragen
dürfen das was ich sehr zu schätzen
begleitet bin ich heute durch herrn
professor schade und dass er mich an
meine hermann professor wiler ist aus
gesundheitlichen gründen heute
verhindert und wer heute morgen wir
möchte ich klarstellen und freue mich
besonders dass michael meyer hermann
heute dabei wir kennen uns gut und ich
hätte zu sagen arbeiten in der
immunologie und auch in der modellierung
sehr davon profitieren wir im
expertenrat aber davon haben wir auch
schon profitiert zu früheren zeiten der
pandemie bewältigung und daher verbindet
uns also eine zusammenarbeit aber auch
eine wertschätzung zumindest von meiner
seite
ich beschreibe die situation in der wir
derzeit sind ich glaube wir haben den
höhepunkt der mikrowelle überschritten
das entspricht ungefähr dem was wir auch
also vorhergesagt hatten wir arbeiten ja
seit wochen seit mehr als fünf wochen
mit dem mit mit dem modell des
robert-koch-institutes von dan mayer und
brockmann womit sich die mikrowelle gut
abbilden lässt der scheitelpunkt war ja
für den vierzehnten februar in dem
modell vorhergesagt dass es ungefähr
auch so hingekommen raten dann so
maßnahmen ergriffen um die fallzahlen zu
senken auch das ist im großen ganzen so
eingetreten wie wir uns das gedacht
haben dass zelaya um es klar zu benennen
den schutz insbesondere der älteren in
deutschland der älteren mitbürger weil
wir dort also eine große zahl von
ungeimpften haben wir müssen davon
ausgehen dass bis zu 12% ungeimpfte bei
den über 60 jährigen haben dass es eine
besondere herausforderung an verlernt
mit denen wir uns vergleichen haben eine
geringere zahl von ungeimpften in dieser
altersgruppe typischerweise zwischen
zwei und fünf prozent aber 12 prozent
ist glaube ich dass wir
außergewöhnlich und das auch eine
außergewöhnliche gefährdung und wir
haben durch die maßnahmen die wir
gemacht haben versucht diese gruppe
möglichst gut zu schützen beispielsweise
durch die 2g plus regelung in den
restaurants aber auch die 2g regelung in
den also im handel die regelungen am
arbeitsplatz und die regelungen die wir
getroffen haben im öpnv
somit kann man sagen ist es uns bisher
gut gelungen durch die omikron werde zu
kommen und das gleiche gilt auch für die
del tabelle daher haben wir im vergleich
zu einer europäischen ländern die
relativ niedrige sterbezahlen
millionen einwohner verteidigen können
haben wir halten können es sind immer
noch zu viele das muss klar gesagt sein
aber wir haben doch also aus meiner
sicht hier konservativ vorgehen können
und da verstehe ich auch weiterhin das
wird ja heutzutage auf stetig gestellt
ob eine so konservative vorgehensweise
richtig ist oder nicht ich finde diese
vorgehensweise richtig und sie ist auch
keine
selbstverständlichkeit dahin möchte ich
bei dieser gelegenheit nochmal allen
bürgern danken dass sie hier mitziehen
mitgezogen haben ich kenne die
einschränkung ich weiß es einzuschätzen
man dank an all diejenigen die sich hier
fair und vorsichtig verhalten haben denn
ihnen verdanken wir die erfolge die wir
haben auf dem hintergrund muss man aber
auch bestehende gefahren hinweisen wir
sind noch nicht wirklich also in
sicheren gewässern
bedeutsam ist das wir bisher noch einen
relativ geringen anteil der baa2
variante von omikron haben etwa 15
prozent andere länder haben wir mehr wir
wissen relativ sicher dass die ba2
variante ansteckender ist und wir müssen
auch davon ausgehen dass sie etwas
schwerer verläufe wo die es bisher nur
in tierexperimentellen studien gezeigt
wurde aber es gibt hinweise darauf dass
das der fall ist somit wenn wir die ba2
variante mehr bekämen in deutschland
dann ist das eine gefährdung des
erfolges den ich gerade vorgetragen habe
und zum zweiten ich habe eben noch
gesagt dass du die älteren rechte
schützen konnten das ist leider
abnehmend der fall das heisst also jetzt
erreicht die welle auch die über 70
jährigen und die über 80-jährigen und
daher haben wir hier also mit
mehrbelastungen und auch gefährdungen
und möglicherweise auch mit mehr
schweren verläufen und todesfällen zu
rechnen dass es wichtig und wir müssen
auch bedenken dass ganz grundsätzlich
die hospitalisierungen gerade bei der
omicron variante nachlaufen das heißt
die infektionen von heute wir sind nicht
morgen schon im krankenhaus sondern die
kommen erst mit deutlicher verzögerung
zum teil an der verzögerung von bis zu
14 tagen daher muss man das was wir
sehen das ist ja nur die inzidenz das
muss man vorsichtig bewerten die
nachlaufende aus spezialisierung ist
weiterhin für uns ein risiko ich sehe
keine gefährdung für eine überlastung
der krankenhäuser zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
aber trotzdem ist es so dass eine solche
nachlaufende aus brutalisierung
natürlich mit vielen schweren verläufen
an er geht und das müssen wir versuchen
zu verhindern kurz zur bewertung der mpk
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ich
habe ich an den beschlüssen aktiv
mitgewirkt ich hatte auch im vorfeld
auch in dieser runde übrigens darauf
hingewiesen dass wir maßvolle
lockerungen uns lassen können aber keine
also maßlosen lockerungen kann
eröffnungen die also überstürzt
geschehen diese maßvollen lockerung
haben wir aus meiner sicht in den drei
stufen die sie ja kennen beschlossen
haben wir vorgetragen und das ist somit
nicht das ende aller kroner maßnahmen
sondern das ist ein langsamer ausstieg
aus den
einschränkungen die wir beschlossen
haben aber man muss hier vorsichtig sein
hier sind auf der grundlage der eben
vorgetragenen risikofaktoren jederzeit
rückfälle möglich und auch das eben von
mir schon beschriebene modell von wenn
meier und brockmann ganz klar wenn wir
zu schnell öffnen dann steigen die
fallzahlen wieder und es gibt da nicht
nur eine verlängerung der welle sondern
stark die wähler wieder an das heißt
selbst das ist nicht ausgeschlossen wir
sind in einer wohlhabenden phase dass
ein wiederanstieg der fallzahlen zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht sicher
ausgeschlossen werden kann was bedeutet
das das bedeutet dass ich hier noch mal
bei dieser gelegenheit auch appelliere
an alle teilnehmer der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und
insbesondere an die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten selbst nicht über
die beschlossenen lockerungen hinaus zu
gehen das ist mein appell wirklich wir
müssen das umsetzen wie ein uhrwerk wie
ein uhrwerk aber wenn wir jetzt
zusätzliche lockerungen einführen wenn
wir versuchen uns zu profilieren als
jemand der besonders schnellen locker
jemand der einmal versuch mit
lockerungsmaßnahmen auch politische
geländegewinne zu machen das wäre falsch
es wird ganz so sagen das ist alles auf
kante genäht und man darf sich da auch
nicht verwirren lassen durch also die
berichterstattung in einigen medien die
man täglich liest wo es also vorgetragen
wird wir könnten doch locker wie
beispielsweise im umliegenden ländern
wie in dänemark beispielsweise oder wie
in england und so weiter man muss immer
in erinnerung rufen wir haben drei bis
viermal so viele ältere ungeimpfte wie
diese länder das muss man immer mit
bedenken dass eine solche lockerung
strategie verbietet sich für uns und
daher appelliere ich hier ausdrücklich
noch einmal an die ministerpräsidenten
und ministerpräsidenten nicht anders
beschlossene zu
halten das maximum was wir uns an
lockerungen leisten können kurzer
rückblick
bevor ich an meine gäste war da gebe
wir haben glaube ich also bisher die
mikrowelle und auch die del-tabelle
einigermaßen gut gemeistert
wir haben es geschafft die große zahl
der ungeimpften beiden älteren zu
schützen uns ist es gelungen die also
deutliche zunahme der sterbefälle
abzuwenden und wir haben wir wirklich
die möglichkeit in das frühjahr hinein
zu kommen mit einer guten gesamtbilanz
das darf nicht gefährdet werden das
dürfen wir nicht zulassen
der ausblick in den herbst ist war dann
geprägt durch die tatsache dass fast
alle mir bekannten wissenschaftler auch
international davon ausgehen dass wir im
herbst noch einmal entsprechende
gefahren sehen werden wählen sie wählen
sehen werden da es besonders
eindrucksvoll die wissenschaftlich
hochwertige auswertung des englischen
said studiums mit den vier szenarien die
da kommen könnten es gibt aber auch
andere also auswertungen ich glaube dass
wir gut beraten sind davon auszugehen
dass wir im herbst entweder im
günstigsten fall wieder eine lage
bekommen dass wieder eine nikon variante
kommt oder die omikron variante selbst
das wäre die günstigste fall es kann
aber auch dazu kommen dass wir wieder
varianten bekommen die tiefer in das
gewebe eindringen als das vereinigung
der fall ist und dann hätten wir eine
viel gefährlichere situation darauf
müssen wir uns vorbereiten
und ich glaube dass das in deutschland
mit der geringen impfbereitschaft gerade
in der gruppe der gefährdeten nur
möglich ist nur möglich ist wenn wir
eine allgemeine impfpflicht einführen
davon bin ich fest überzeugt daher
begrüßt dass der deutsche bundestag in
gruppen anträgen sich dieser problematik
annimmt ich werde selbst den antrag der
gruppe schmidt damen und henning
zeichnen ich werde mich also dem antrag
der impfpflicht ab 18 anschließend wie
das auch bundeskanzler scholz tut und
wie das wahrscheinlich auch andere
regierungsmitglieder tun werden trotzdem
ist es muss gesagt sein alle anträge
antrag also ab 50 wieder ab 18 das sind
sehr wichtige anträge und ich hoffe dass
wir dazu ein ergebnis kommen so viel
vielleicht von meiner seite und
weitergeben an den schatten das vielen
dank dass sie
vielen dank guten morgen sehr geehrte
damen und herren unsere daten deuten
darauf hin dass der höhepunkt der
omicron werde überschritten ist die
fallzahlen sind in den letzten tagen
bundesweit leicht gesunken je nach
bundesland kann das noch etwas variieren
auch die anzahl der durchgeführten pcr
test ist zum ersten mal seit langem
leicht gesunken tendenziell auch der
anteil der positiven pcr test unter ihm
das bestätigt dass die fallzahlen
tatsächlich zurückgehen allerdings ist
der scheitelpunkt für die
intensivstationen noch nicht erreicht
weil menschen mit schwerer erkrankungen
etwas später aufgenommen werden und auch
längere zeit dort behandelt werden auch
für die todesfälle sehen wir noch keinen
sicheren rückgang dennoch kann man sagen
das virus und seine folgen werden durch
zunehmende immunisierung und durch die
bisherigen maßnahmen immer weiter
ausgebremst die hospitalisierung steigen
im verhältnis der fallzahlen moderat
dieser erfolg macht eine stufenweise und
vorsichtige rücknahme der maßnahmen
möglich aber natürlich unter beobachtung
der situation das ist eine erfreuliche
entwicklung aber trotzdem müssen wir die
situation weiter ernst nehmen erstens
sind kliniken und intensivstationen nach
wie vor zum teil deutlich belastet dass
es regional etwas unterschiedlich
zweitens ist micro nach wie vor weit
verbreitet die meisten landkreise haben
immer noch eine ent sieben tage ins
events von über 1000 das
infektionsrisiko bleibt also im moment
noch hoch und drittens haben wir eine
zunahme des anteils der omicron sub
linie baa2 herr minister hat er es
bereits erwähnt die nach ersten daten
leichter übertragbar ist und wenn sie
sich weiter durchsetzt ist es nicht
auszuschließen dass die fallzahlen
langsamer sinken oder auch wieder
ansteigen im moment nehmen die
hospitalisierung tänzen und die intensiv
beliebten besonders bei den älteren noch
zu ausbrüche in alten- und pflegeheim
leben ebenfalls zu diese besonders
gefährdeten gruppen müssen weiter
geschützt werden gerade im hinblick auf
die bevorstehende lockerung deshalb ist
es wichtig schutzmaßnahmen
krankenhäusern und pflegeheimen weiter
aufrechtzuerhalten
und bitte bleiben sie besonders
vorsichtig wenn sie ältere menschen oder
menschen mit vorerkrankungen treffen die
ein erhöhtes risiko für einen schweren
verlauf haben waren sie vorher ein test
auch wenn sie geimpft oder genesen sind
halten sie abstand und wenn sie sich
drinnen treffen tragen sie am besten
eine maske und lüften reichlich ich
möchte an dieser stelle auch noch einmal
die bedeutung der impfungen ansprechen
eine vollständige impfung und vor allem
die auffrischimpfung schützen sehr gut
vor schweren verläufen und todesfällen
aufbau mikron dass wir bislang
vergleichsweise gut durch die omikron
werde gekommen sind haben wir zum großen
teil der umsicht der bevölkerung zu
verdanken und der tatsache dass ich ein
der menschen hat impfen und auffrischen
lassen
trotzdem sind noch immer herr minister
hat es erwähnt millionen menschen
geimpft auch bei den über 60-jährigen
die besonders gefährdet sind ich möchte
daher noch einmal an alle
unentschlossenen appellieren bitte
lassen sie sich impfen auch mit blick
auf die zukunft denn die pandemie ist
noch nicht vorbei und saß der saas
corona virus 2 wird nicht mehr
verschwinden wir müssen uns darauf
einstellen dass es auch in zukunft
weitere coop 19 wellen geben wird wie
sie genau verlaufen werden können wir
noch nicht vorhersagen das hängt von
verschiedenen faktoren ab zum beispiel
ob es neue varianten geben wird ob es
gelingt die impflücken zu schließen und
auch die bevölkerung ihren impfschutz
aufrecht erhält aber eines ist heute
schon klar je mehr menschen eine
immunität gegen des ascona virus 2
aufweisen desto besser können wir mit 19
auch in zukunft bewältigen und die
impfung und ist und bleibt der beste und
sicherste weg so diese immunität
herzlichen
machen
vielen dank ich möchte erstmal einen
positiven satz sagen nämlich es licht am
ende des tunnels und das freue ich mich
dass ich das mal sagen kann weil ich ja
eher den ruf habe immer negative dinge
zu sagen und dass die aktuelle situation
lässt glaube ich diesen satz jetzt
wirklich zu und wir haben jetzt
angesehen das ist sehr viele beschlüsse
gibt wegen der planung von öffnungen und
ich glaube da muss man ganz genau
hingucken wie man das jetzt im detail
durchführt erstmal der zweite erfolg den
hatte karl lauterbach auch schon genannt
ist dass die zahl der toten die wir in
deutschland haben ich habe das erst mal
kumulativ angeschaut über die gesamte
partie hinweg relativ zum europäischen
durchschnitt niedriger liegt deutlich
niedriger also wir haben 1400 tote auf
eine million menschen das ist eine
erschreckend hohe zahl ist findig und
europäischen durchschnitt sind es 2200
wenn man nach südkorea guckt sind es 140
also man hat schon auch länder die das
besser hingekriegt haben und das sind
meistens die länder die an niedrig
incidents strategie gefahren haben
relativ konsequent und das muss man sich
auch klar machen dass es also vorteile
hat wenn man diese strategie fährt auch
wirtschaftlich übrigens in südkorea aber
es gibt auch andere beispiele und man
kann darüber stunden diskutieren das
wollte ich nur mal so als größenordnung
sehen man kann mit 140 toten auf 111 1
millionen menschen auch durch diese
panne gekommen und ich würde gerne dass
deutschland jetzt wenigstens im
europäischen vergleich diese vorrangige
spiele die positive stellung beibehält
das wäre sehr erfreulich wenn wir das
schaffen würden und insofern sind die
öffnungen die wir jetzt machen
tatsächlich genau zu planen denn wir
sind in einer situation wie wir
rohrbruch versuchen zu kontrollieren wir
halten die hand drauf dass in unsere
maßnahmen zb die masken das ist nicht
ganz dicht aber es ist natürlich nicht
so eine gute idee die hand weg zu nehmen
bevor man den haupthahn abgedreht hat
und vor dem hintergrund sollte man
tatsächlich genau wissen wann man öffnet
wie viel man öffnet und man sollte es
stufenweise tun also dass man sehen kann
welche öffnung welchen effekt hat also
es ist wichtig dass man eine zeit hat
zwischen den verschiedenen öffnungs
schritten damit man sieht ob diese
öffnung vielleicht zu viel gewesen ist
gerade im hinblick auf die unsicherheit
die wir haben was ba2 anbelangt denn wir
wissen noch nicht genau wie viel hat
anstecken da diese variante sein wird
und wie die krankheitslast sein wird das
sind dinge die im moment noch eruiert
werden und da müssen wir gucken dass das
tatsächlich jetzt nicht zu einem
wiederanstieg der fälle führt es wird
sicherlich zu einer verlängerung der
schulter gebe jetzt sehen führen und vor
dem hintergrund ist es ein vabanque
spiel wir haben in der zweiten welle das
schon mal durchgespielt da hatten wir
auch eine horizontale bewegung und haben
in die horizontale bewegung geöffnet und
hatten dann ein deutlichen zweiten sieg
in der in der zweiten welle gehabt wir
sollten diesen fehler nicht wiederholen
das wäre mir ein starkes anliegen ok
also wir können jetzt
versuchen diese öffnung in der geplanten
weise durchzuführen es gibt eine
bedingung die der expertenrat daran
gestellt hat das kann man in der
sechsten stellungnahme nachlesen und die
bedingung ist dass die krankheit lassen
in krankenhäusern stabil abnimmt und ich
denke dass das ein sinnvolles kriterium
ist damit man eben keine weitere zunahme
der krankheitslast und der toten hat
sondern dass man eben durch diese welle
durch kommt ohne dass so viele menschen
sterben
jetzt gucke ich mal ein bisschen nach
vorne was wir gerne wollen und das wort
ist ja öfter schon gefallen er ist dass
das jetzt die variante ist die uns in
den endemischen zustand bringt was heißt
das jetzt eigentlich ganz konkret können
das heißt konkret dass das produkt von
re produktionszahl und den subtilen in
der bevölkerung 1 wird also wir haben
eine re produktionszahl in dieser
variante die zwischen sechs und zehn
liegt da gibt es unterschiedliche
schätzungen und wir brauchen eben in
dementsprechend eine subjektive
bevölkerung die im bereich von 1 60 bis
1 zehntel liegt das haben wir nicht ganz
geschafft denn das ist eine innen es
geld variante und das heißt auch unter
den geimpften gibt es eine infektion
wahrscheinlichkeit deswegen sieht man ja
auch überall dass selbst die dreimal
geimpften tatsächlich infiziert werden
also wie kann man da hinkommen ist die
große frage ist wie werden die die grund
immunität in der bevölkerung erreichen
die man braucht um tatsächlich die in
diesen endemischen zustand überzugehen
und da ist natürlich das impfen in der
entscheidende faktor denn wir haben
einfach in der gesamtbevölkerung viel zu
viele die nicht geimpft sind und die
einfach wohl ne rabl sind jetzt
wahrscheinlich wird man sehen dass also
wenn jetzt die öffnung so stattfinden
dass die ungeimpften menschen wieder an
dem gesellschaftlichen leben komplett
teilnehmen können das dann eben genau
diese gruppe auch infiziert wird und das
wird auch die todesrate hochziehen denn
diese menschen sind einfach nicht
geschützt die haben keinen immunschutz
überhaupt bisher sind sie hätten
vielleicht eine andere variante schon
mal gehabt und das heißt wir werden
damit rechnen müssen dass in dieser
gruppe jetzt dann tatsächlich vermehrt
todesfälle und schwere verläufe die auch
nicht lustig sind
auftreten werden
man sollte sich auch klar machen in
bezug auf die grund immunität die man
erreichen möchte dass eine alleinige
omikron infektion nicht gegen die
varianten delta und vorher schützt also
das sind relativ gute daten inzwischen
auf dem markt zu sehen dass also
menschen die zwei drei impfungen gehabt
haben und dann omikron bekommen dass die
einen sehr guten schutz für alle
varianten haben die im moment da sind
und ein natürlich kann mir nichts über
die zukünftigen varianten sagen aber
wenn menschen jetzt eben nur omikron
gehabt haben haben die keinen schutz
gegen delta das ist eine wichtige
bemerkung insofern als dass das bedeutet
dass im herbst delta wieder hochkommen
kann wenn die menschen nur omikron
bekommen haben es ist also ein weiterer
grund um tatsächlich auch diese menschen
die jetzt noch gar nicht geimpft sind
zunächst zu impfen und dann wird ja
jeder irgendwann omikron gehabt haben
dieser schutz ist optimal und gegen alle
varianten wenn man jetzt nur omikron hat
was ihr der allgemeine glaube ist man
könnte jetzt einfach am mikro an kriegen
und dann wäre alles gut das ist nicht
der fall dann können die alten varianten
wieder hoch kommen sollte man sich klar
machen ich möchte noch ein letztes wort
zu lamco wird sagen longo wird ist
glaube ich in dieser gesellschaft immer
noch weitgehend
nicht hinreichend berücksichtigt er
singt eine große zahl von menschen die
tatsächlich langfristige leiden haben
wenn sie eine kurve erkrankung haben und
das ist ein
nicht nur wirtschaftlich ist sondern
auch psychisches und mentales problem in
der gesellschaft das gab jetzt gerade
gestern eine studie die in amerika groß
angelegt war und wo gezeigt worden ist
dass also die menschen die eine kuh wird
erkrankung hatten massiv
höhere sekunde erfolgen haben
langfristige art also da sind zeiträume
von einem jahr jetzt untersucht worden
und also ich meine wenn man ein jahr
lang mit massiven problemen zu tun hat
das möchte man eigentlich auch nicht und
aus israel wissen wir da gibt es eine
studie in israel die zeigt auch da hilft
die impfung also auch die longo witt
nachwirkungen sind deutlich verringert
wenn man vorher geimpft war und dann von
corona infiziert worden ist vielen dank
erstmal danke auch ihn ich schon eine
ganze reihe an fragen auf meiner liste
ich beginne im saal und bin erst bei
wolfs kempf und dann bei herrn heinrich
guten morgen vielen dank für die
ausführungen ich habe eine frage an
herrn lauterbach und zwar zum pflege
bonus den die regierung versprochen hat
scholz hatte angekündigt bis ende januar
kommt da ein vorschlag von ihnen ließen
jetzt der standbein pflege bonus ja ich
stand ist der dass wir in der tat an
einem vorschlag arbeiten und dass ich
davon ausgehe dass wir den in der ersten
hälfte der nächsten woche vorstellen
können
wird es weiterhin auf die intensivpflege
bezogen sein können sie schon
grössenordnungen ich bitte um
verständnis dass sowie da ist also im
konsens der partner in der ampel
zu einem
konzertierten vorschlag kommen aber ich
kann also
an und vergewissern dass wir am anfang
der nächsten woche da etwas vorliegen
werden die vor die vorbereitung sind
weit fortgeschritten
ja eigentlich was den handel vom nachdem
tom watson herr lauterbach am wenn man
sich die europakarte anschaut dann gibt
es ja nach wie vor für sehr viele
europäische länder reisewarnungen wird
von nicht notwendigen touristischen
reisen gewarnt
19 bedingte reise waren denn ja eine
sehr große einschränkung für millionen
menschen mit familienangehörigen
partnern in anderen ländern
dabei sind die inzidenz und jan in
anderen ländern vergleichbar hoch
omikron es überall dominant die frage
deswegen ist es nach wie vor nicht
ratsam in andere europäische staaten zu
reisen raten sie nach wie vor davon ab
aber da kann man daran eigentlich
zwischen absehen wie passen die hörsel
waren um an die beschlüsse der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sind eben
ja bekannt ich möchte mich insbesondere
dafür einsetzen oder nicht dafür
einsetzen ich möchte und werde umsetzen
um spezies nicht so sein dass die also
einschränkungen für familien mit kindern
wegfallen weil die sind zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt also auf der grundlage dass
also chemischen geschehens in ganz
europa nicht vertretbar wenn die
rückfrage mit dem blick wenn jetzt
jemand meine reise für das frühjahr hat
im sommer plant ins ins ausland wie das
aus ihrer sicht jetzt bedenkenlos oder
was muss beachtet werden
bedenken muss ist derzeit nichts zu
planen
professor meyer hermann ist ja
vorgetragen wir müssen vorsichtig sein
viele länder öffnen derzeit rückfälle
sind denkbar die wir noch in modellen
abgebildet ich hatte darauf hingewiesen
dass er selbst auch in dem modell von
dan mayer und brockmann
zu sehen ist das also wir von der
schulter wieder auf einer auf steigende
fallzahl wechseln könnten wenn wir hier
in einem also tatsächlichen r wert von
über 1 zurück geraten das ist einfach so
wenn die schutzmaßnahmen die wir greifen
nicht mehr ausreichend wirken um damit
also zu erreichen dass wir bei der
beschränkten zahl derjenigen
desinfizieren können und er tatsächlich
und sagen sich infizieren können durch
den albert in einem ungleichgewicht
kommen dann haben wir schwierigkeiten
das kann ich auch für andere länder
nicht ausschließen somit also ist also
bedenken freie reiseempfehlungen jetzt
leider noch nicht möglich wir
kontrollieren jahren mit mühe das
geschehen im eigenen land und haben
wenig möglichkeiten das geschehen im
ausland vorherzusagen ich würde zwei
digitale fragen mal zusammen nehmen der
kollege reuter vom ard hauptstadtstudio
fraktion impfstoff nowaks wann beginnen
die impfungen damit und wie viele
impfdosen stehen für die erste woche zur
verfügung wie viele insgesamt
und der kollege pansen von zdf verkauf
zu nowaks
es dazu eine werbekampagne geben soll
und wie diese aussieht wir erwarten also
am 21
februar das haus am montag erwarten wir
1,4 millionen dosen des
impfstoffes in der woche darauf nochmal
eine million dann mit einer gewissen
verzögerung also weitere also chargen
das unternehmen ist in der vergangenheit
mehrfach also
aufgefallen durch also hinweise dass die
lieferungen nicht fristgerecht erfolgen
können ich gehe jetzt davon aus wir
haben wir sind im engen kontakt engen
austausch dass wir nächste woche
beliefert werden diese lieferungen gehen
dann haben die länder verteilt auf der
grundlage der also des königsteiner
schlüssel und somit bekämen die länder
die
bevölkerungsgröße bekämen sie dann also
den lebensstoff zugeteilt und werden ihn
wahrscheinlich im wesentlichen primär
also im wesentlichen dafür einsetzen für
die einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
also so nutzen und ich dem michael meier
man ausdrücklich zu dass wir und der
schade hat ist auch gesagt also dass wir
hier vorsichtig sein müssen wir also
sind also an einem punkt wo wir sagen
kann dass wir wieder erhebliche probleme
in den pflegeeinrichtungen und bekommen
im karl genau sondern auch
pflegeeinrichtungen
das möchte ich auf keinen fall hier
stimme ich ausdrücklich bundeskanzlerin
scholz zu der ja mehrfach darauf
hingewiesen hat dass es gar nicht also
akzeptieren können dass in den
pflegeeinrichtungen noch einmal
schutzbedürftige menschen versterben
daher also
daher erklärt sich auch unser besonderes
engagement für die 1 für die
durchsetzung der einrichtungs bezogenen
impfpflicht ich weiß dass das schwer ist
für die länder und ich weiß dass das
auch die gesundheitsämter herausforderer
was müssen wir lassen und dafür wird der
nowaks impfstoff im wesentlichen
eingesetzt und die frage zur
werbekampagne ist noch offen da es
spezielles geplant ist und wie diese
werbekampagne aussehen wie wir planen
derzeit keine spezifische
werbekampagne für einen also einzelnen
impfstoff das wäre auch schwer
vertretbar war die impfstoffe die wir
haben sind die aale hochwirksam und da
wurde ja der eindruck entstehen als wenn
es hier eine also als wenn es hier also
an der unterscheidung gebe auf die wir
in unserer kampagne hinweisen müssen
dass nicht der fall dann bin ich im saal
erst bei hamm buchsteiner und dann bei
frau stieg
lauterbach zu den basisschutz maßnahmen
nachdem zwanzigster märz was wird
notwendig seien aus ihrer sicht
arbeitsplatz da gibt es ja ein paar
veränderungen im papier aber bei den
schutzmaßnahmen am arbeitsplatz ist es
noch nicht so konkret also pflicht test
angebotspflicht 2g 3g was sollte aus
ihrer sicht geld also ich möchte den
verhandlungen dem deutschen bundestag
nicht vorweg greifen wir haben ja einen
ersten entwurf für das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz sehr kurzfristig
erstellt
kollege justizminister marco buschmann
und mein haus das ist die grundlage für
die diskussion im deutschen bundestag
und dort werden diese dinge dann im
einzelnen geregelt es ist auf jeden fall
so dass wir am arbeitsplatz sparte
schutzmaßnahmen benötigen das aus meiner
sicht kann man nicht sagen der
arbeitsplatz ist jetzt wieder wie vor
der pandemie das wird nicht so sein dass
also wer eine gefährdung der also
arbeitnehmer
und aber die spezifischen maßnahmen da
bin ich einfach um verständnis da ist
meine rolle da sich mit buschmann
zusammen
handwerklich also sehr bewegliches
träger gesetz einbringen aber die
eigentlichen maßnahmen werden vom
bundestag beschlossen und wünsche dafür
und aufforderungen haben ja die länder
im mpk beschluss formuliert so ist die
konstruktion im mpk beschluss stehen die
wünsche und empfehlungen der
ministerpräsidenten der bundestag macht
das gesetz das eigentliche träger
größtem die fsg haben wir erstellt und
damit wird gearbeitet
wird diese formulierungshilfe nächste
woche schon im kabinett seien und warum
sind sie als regierung so zurückhaltend
bei dem thema sie müssen ja das
vorangehen warum wird die entscheidung
in der form dem parlament so überlassen
es ist ja also etwas was wir im letzten
jahr also noch mal ganz klar beschlossen
haben das parlament will
die also
beschloss hoheit bei diesen zentralen
maßnahmen für die bevölkerung und das
kann ich auch gut nachvollziehen dass
also war ja lange zeit das problem dass
also die schutzmaßnahmen von der
regierung beschlossen worden sind und
das parlament weitestgehend außen vor
war weil es eben diese ich sage mal
beauftragung der regierung gegeben hat
diese maßnahmen durchzusetzen das hat
uns auch gut durch die erste und die
zweite werde pandemie gebracht aber
irgendwann war dann der punkt erreicht
das parlament gesagt hat wir wollen dass
wieder selbst machen und das stelle ich
nicht stetig sondern das ist jetzt erst
mal die lage und ich bin ganz sicher
dass das parlament mit dieser
verantwortung in einer art und weise
umgehen wird dass wir ein sehr gutes
gesetz nach dem zwanzigsten märz haben
die zukunft gucken was glauben sie
wielange werden wir mit dieser pandemie
noch zu tun haben und wie begründen sie
das ja ich bin hier immer so in einer
situation wo ich aus wie ihr mann
hermann schon gesagt hat wir sind oft
die überbringer der schwierigen
nachricht muss man sozusagen und wenn
ich ehrlich sein soll ist es so dass ich
davon ausgehe dass er noch sehr lange
mit der pandemie zu tun haben werden
da kann man wirklich in zeiträumen auch
von zehn jahren denken ich will das
einfach an einem beispiel erläutern ja
eine gruppe in der bevölkerung wo die
impfstoffe wirken aber nicht ausreichend
wirken im boden so prämierte menschen wo
ich einfach die schutzwirkung nicht so
hinbekommen mit die notwendig ist um
sehr schwere verläufe zu verhindern wie
viele menschen sind das wissen noch
nicht was genau das sind menschen nach
einer krebserkrankung nach chemotherapie
menschen mit angeborenen immundefekt
menschen mit erworbenen immundefekten
wenn ich es als zusammenzähle komme ich
also auch viele menschen
der größenordnung 2 prozent und mehr
aber ganz konstruktiv gemessen ganz
konservativ gemessen und für diese leute
endet die pandemie nicht also mit also
also mit der impfung war die impfungen
dort allein und nicht ausreichend werden
das sind aber auch menschen die wir
schützen müssen weil ich jetzt nicht
sagen also wir machen alles wie früher
ihr bleibt drinnen sondern außerdem
müssen sogar kinder dabei und daher wird
es also nicht so sein dass wir zur
normalität zurückkehren es ist auch so
also was ich immer höre die endemische
der in dem ist-zustand der wird quasi
angestrebt was wenn das etwas ist was
wir feiern müssten also wir sind
befinden sind in dem ich hin zustand der
endemischen zustand bedeutet es gibt
immer wieder ausbrüche von denen auch
nicht wenige schwer verlaufen werden und
wo wir dann auch wieder todesfälle haben
und wo wir möglicherweise neue varianten
bekommen somit also die gute nachricht
ist mit was in einer richtung fährt ist
der zug der also grund immunisiert das
ist der zug mit dem velo unterwegs sind
wo der also der schutz der bevölkerung
besser wird aber der zug nimmt nicht
alle gleichermaßen also mit und dann
muss auch dazu anhalten von daher werden
wir damit noch länger zu tun haben
darauf müssen wir uns einstellen weil
sie ergänzt ja ich würde gern noch
ergänzen dass man vielleicht positiv
anmerken könnte
dass das bike protein
grundsätzlich bei allen varianten sehr
wichtig ist und dass wir deswegen mit
antikörpern die gegen das bike protein
spezifisch sind tatsächlich weitgehende
schutzwirkung über verschiedene
varianten hinweg aufrecht erhalten
können so dass wir wahrscheinlich davon
ausgehen können dass ein potenzial
dieses virus sich zu mutieren vielleicht
nicht so groß ist wie vielleicht bei
anderen
wie bei influenza zum beispiel dass wir
eine grundschutz wirkung der aktuellen
impfungen auch bei zukünftigen varianten
auf rechnern sie total spekulative
aussage aber ich würde das von der
aktuellen situation hier so bewerten
das heißt ja auch dass man
damit rechnen
kein bisschen direkt ans mikro sprechen
versteht man sie schlecht dass wir im
herbst mit steigender infektionszahlen
rechnen müssen ich war ja so den
eindruck dass in den letzten zwei jahren
immerhin so diesem herbst
reingeschlittert ist jetzt sagen sie im
pflicht und basisschutz reicht aus um
nicht im september oktober wieder da zu
stehen
ich glaube tatsächlich werden wir die
impfpflicht umgesetzt bekommen und
könnten die besonders vollen radeln
älteren also schützen
in kombination mit anderen also
früheren überwachung des geschehens das
infektionsgeschehen surveillance und
darüber hinaus eben den arzneimitteln
die wir also besorgen konnten hier
verspreche ich mir besonders viel also
in dem präparat parcours wird nicht
alleine wir haben auch andere als ein
mittel beschafft max hoff ist also ist
also etwas was ich für sehr wirkungsvoll
hatte wenn es früh gegeben wird wenn man
in dieser kombination also operiert wenn
man den kann man im herbst also einen
rückfall vermeiden wir im letzten jahr
aber wie gesagt ja die das zentrale
problem ist wirklich die große gruppe
der ungeimpften eltern und wir müssen
auch beachten na ja man hat es ja gesagt
also viele schätzen das falsch ein die
auch nikon oder infektionen schützt
nicht gut vor anderen varianten und
schützen möglicherweise noch nichtmals
gut vor einem rückfall mit amerika und
das ist noch nicht genau aber erst
gestern ist wieder eine studie
erschienen im jungen journal of medicine
an der besonders renommierten
fachzeitschrift und der sogenannten
sauerland gruppe aus uk die klar gezeigt
hat also wenn ich die infektionen mit
oregon gehabt habe und dann insel habe
ich einen sehr guten schutz
erreicht offenbar um diesen schutz zu
erreichen schon eine einzige impfung
daher lassen sie mich diese gelegenheit
nochmal nutzen was ich an alle hier
appelliere die uns zuhören
diejenigen die dick und infektionen
jetzt gehabt haben mit einer impfung
nachlegen wird ein guter schutz bereits
erreicht und das ist also
unterschätzende maßen also das ja auch
eine gelegenheit wenn jetzt schon die
omikron infektion nicht verhindert
werden konnte wenn man in dem
entsprechenden abstand den das lka klar
vorgegeben hat dann eine impfung nach
legt eine einzige impfung sollte hier
schon sehr viel zu bringen dann ist man
gut geschützt das muss auch für den
herbst gelten
ja ich wollte dem missverständnis
vorbeugen dass man erst darauf warten
muss auch nicht gehabt zu haben um sich
dann zu impfen sondern das funktioniert
auch umgekehrt
man kann sich ja auch zunächst impfen
lassen und dann immer noch omikron
bekommen haben und auch das ist ein sehr
guter schutz ich wollte allgemein noch
zu der frage ergänzen
dass wir uns klar machen müssen das ist
letztlich ernüchterung geht dass wir
irgendwann uns nicht mehr alle
infizieren sondern es geht darum dass
wir das in einen normalen zustand
überführen dass wir irgendwann
coronaviren haben und diese krankheiten
eben wie ein schnupfen behandeln können
es geht also darum dass wir eine
grundimmunisierung die uns davor bewahrt
schwere verläufe zu bekommen das ist das
ziel was wir im moment verfolgen und das
langfristige ziel was wir erreichen
müssen deswegen ist die
grundimmunisierung wichtig und die
impfung hilft uns massiv dabei dieses
ziel zu erreichen und erst dann können
wir die gesellschaft wieder komplett auf
machen
auf jeden fall schon mal vorweg sagen
dass wir nicht alle fragen heute
schaffen werden da bitte ich um
verständnis ich nehme jetzt noch eine
digitale frage von den kollegen geinitz
von der faz zum schutz von kindern die
auch nicht konkret adressiert es nicht
richtig einfach mal in die runde wer
sich angesprochen gefühlt
die medizinischen
fachgesellschaften fordern ein
generelles ende der masken test und
quarantäne pflicht in schulen und kitas
wann wird das kommen oder bleiben die
empfehlungen im sinne des schutzes
bestehen
ja vielleicht
schaffe ich das kurz aufs nächste und
begrüße ich ausdrücklich
die vorzügliche ausarbeitung auch zum
thema kinder vom expertenrat das ist
wirklich also für uns als
bundesregierung sehr wertvolle eine sehr
spezifische gute
ausarbeitung und
der expertenrat war es ja darauf hin
dass auch der schutz der kinder vor
infektion sehr wichtig ist sehr wichtig
ist also ich also ärgere mich immer wenn
ich lesen muss dass also die infektion
für kinder unbedenklich sah ich habe
auch schon gelesen dass für kinder die
infektion
unbedenklicher sei als die impfung das
ist alles einfach schlicht falsch das
muss man doch klar sagen und das ist
auch nicht die position also des
expertenrates und ist auch nicht
abgebildet durch die wissenschaftliche
literatur daher müssen wir die kinder
schützen die kinder
brauchen unseren schutz und was ich also
hier nur für die bundesregierung sagen
kann ist dass wir nicht wünschen
nachdem die erwachsenen jetzt also
langsam etwas besser geschützt sind dass
wir dann den schutz der kinder komplett
aufgeben das kann nicht sagen also wir
müssen unsere kinder auch mitnehmen in
diesem geschützten raum hinein und hier
nicht also eine durchleuchtung oft in
den letzten monaten bis zum besseren
wetter zu lassen das ist nicht
akzeptabel
die auch medizinisch nicht akzeptabel
und das oft km fall die haltung der
bundesregierung
daher fordern wir alle dazu auf die
kinder gut zu schützen dazu zählen
natürlich bei der hohen also incidents
die wird derzeit noch haben der schaden
hat ja dankenswerterweise das eben wenn
man klar ausgeführt dass wir längst noch
nicht in dem bereich sind dass wir von
einer niedrigen des lebens sprechen
können das ist gerade bei der hohen
instituts natürlich die kinder auch
durch masken geschützt sein
also ich glaube ein vorrangiges ziel
sollte sein dass wir die schulen offen
halten können und dann muss man die
frage stellen wie man das erreichen kann
denn ich denke die bildungs ausfälle die
unsere kinder gehabt haben sind
hinreichend dramatisch und es gibt da
zwei aspekte der eine aspekt der die
kinder auch mental belastet ist das
überhaupt nicht wissen wie die aktuelle
situation ist und wie es weitergeht also
die planungsunsicherheit halte ich für
einen massiven respekt habe ich mit
einigen soziologen auch darüber
unterhalten
die darin das hauptproblem sehen das ist
also dauernd hin und her switchen
zwischen verschiedenen regeln also dass
man dann mal die masken tragen darf dann
musste er hat man sie nicht tragen dann
fällt der unterricht aus dass dieser
wechsel unterricht und sowie das hin und
her geht das ist eine massive belastung
für die psyche der kinder und
jugendlichen ich denke dass wir einfach
dafür sorgen müssen dass die schule
stabil und gleichmäßig offen bleibt und
dementsprechend kann man die masken in
den schulen dann absetzen wenn dass
dieses ziel nicht gefährdet
vielleicht sollte man auch bei dem
kontext kinder einfach noch mal sagen
dass die impfungen jedoch bis zu den 12
jährigen klar empfohlen sind und wir
haben da eben auch noch keine impfquote
gehen wir wirklich als befriedigend
empfinden können da wäre es schon auch
gut wenn wenn letztendlich aktiv mit
daran gearbeitet würde dass die kinder
für die eine impfempfehlung da ist durch
die impfung geschützt werden das würde
ich als eine voraussetzung sehen und
dann ist natürlich auch immer noch offen
ob die empfehlung bei den bis zu
fünfjährigen so bleibt also nur
friedlich risikogruppen oder ob die
stiko da die empfehlung erweitert
beschäftigt sich mit dem thema
regelmäßig und es ist auch gut möglich
dem kann ich natürlich nicht vorgreifen
das ist hier noch eine erweiterung der
impfung gibt und das würde natürlich die
situation auch noch mal ändern im
hinblick auf letztendlich andere
schutzmaßnahmen aber ganz ohne
schutzmaßnahmen da würde ich auch von
unserer seite zustimmen wäre im moment
bei den hohen instanzen die situation
noch sehr schwierig dann wechsle ich
wieder in den saal ich bin erst bei
herrn mohamed und dann beißt
man frage an professor meyer hellmann
wir haben wunderbar die umkämpfte
überzeugend gewappnet und alles mögliche
und sie haben von mentalen und
psychischen
auswirkungen in schwierigkeiten und
alles mögliche aber sie haben auch
gesagt das sind vier millionen sind ihr
nicht willig und jetzt wir gewusst als
er und kämpfte sich millionen mehr als
60 millionen mussten will das mass der
maske vor dem makabren fund diese
menschen oder gibt es keine krone
stresst studien oder das tragen von
masken dass die männchen auch für die
nerven ein
ich nehme an die frage ist an mich
gerichtet also dass die masken einem auf
die nerven gehen das verstehe ich ist
aber eigentlich in anbetracht des leides
was er mit diesem virus ausgelöst wird
kein wirklich relevantes argument
ehrlich gesagt ich denke dass die masken
ein extrem guter schutz und eine gute
möglichkeit sind ohne dass wir uns
ernsthaft anstrengen müssen
die pandemie unter kontrolle zu halten
es ist ein relativ effektive maßnahme
gerade auch jetzt bei dem nikon virus
was er im oberen respiratorischen trakt
arbeitet und weniger hände lunge ist ist
die aus streuung relativ hoch über den
oberen trakt und deswegen über die maske
sehr gut geschützt es wäre also
eigentlich keine gute idee an der stelle
jetzt die maske abzusetzen solange wir
so hohe in sidenten haben wir haben
jetzt die höchsten instanz in der
gesamten pandemie zeit und also insofern
dass masken tragen ist relativ wenig
eingriff also ich mache lieber die
restaurants auf und trage dann in die
maske
man sieht dass deutschland ist strenger
mit diesem osken pflicht alles alle
anderen europäer nach beiden länder also
psychisch das wirklich schwer wenn man
mit dem zug fünf stunden fahren und muss
ich muss sagen oder über eine maske
tragen denn das ist irgendwie streng
ja ich kann nur wiederholen was ich
gesagt habe und mir reichen 1400 tote
auf eine million menschen ich bin froh
dass es weniger sind als in anderen
ländern
eine frage an minister lauterbach zum
thema impfstoffe ja aber es war kurz
davor die jungs bildung auch gesagt dass
sie ganz bewusst mehr impfstoff bestellt
als nötig ist damit wir gewappnet sind
mit wievielen überschüssigen impfstoff
rechnen sie in den nächsten monaten bei
dem im moment sehr langsamem tempo wie
viel wird vielleicht vernichtet werden
müssen wie stefan kovacs abgegeben
werden und eine frage normale anleihen
bei einer frage hessen die möglichkeit
der nachfrage dass ich heute streng
waren tut mir leid
ja vielen dank die frage kann jetzt noch
nicht klar beantwortet werden die
impfkampagne läuft ja noch das ist gar
keine frage
und wir werden also sehen ja jetzt das
problem dass also die impfstoffe über
die zeit auch an wirkung verlieren daher
ist es also
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht klar
wer also für den herbst noch einmal
geimpft werden muss
und wir haben den impfstoff so beschafft
dass wir zu jedem zeitpunkt also auch
beispielsweise wenn es wissenschaftlich
notwendig würde eine vierte impfung
durchführen zu können wir rechnen jetzt
also mit dem bau und dämmstoff für
omicron deutlich später er ist also im
mai
und wer also brauchen auch im stoff also
für die zweite hälfte des jahres dass es
etwas schwieriger also abzuschätzen mit
welchem stoff man dann arbeiten kann es
kann sagen dass dann wieder eine andere
variante kommt wenn eine andere variante
käme wäre möglicherweise anrainer
omikron impfstoffe biotec nicht die
erste wahl das kann man also zumindest
nicht ausschließen daher ist die
impfstoffe schaffung strategie für dich
selbst stehe einer die also mit einer
gewissen redundanz arbeitete ich wie
folgt beschreiben möchte
die bevölkerung soll geimpft werden
können wenn eine weitere impfung
notwendig wird entweder mit einem
omikron impfstoff oder mit einem nicht
mit dem stoff und für beides muss ich
gleichzeitig beschaffen weil wir nicht
wissen welche also welche variante kommt
und das ist der hintergrund also der
sache beschaffungsstrategie die
frage also wird im stoff verkommen oder
nicht also wir werden den impfstoff der
also auf das haltbarkeitsdatum zuläuft
den werden wir entsprechend dort
einsetzen wo jetzt unmittelbar benötigt
wird und in der tat also die gute
nachricht ist die wir können unsere
verpflichtungen kovacs gegenüber können
wir einhalten das ist ja auch an der
wichtige botschaft also das ist ja es
kann ja nicht falsch sagen wenn wir
unsere kovacs verpflichtungen voll
erfüllen können
mit den ländern geregelt dass sie offen
bleibt
ja wir haben mit den ländern auf der
ebene gesundheitsministerkonferenz
geeint dass die impfzentren offen
bleiben weil wir eben also auch fließend
impfungen anbieten wurden und die länder
haben dafür auch entsprechende
finanzielle mittel vom bund
beantragt und ich gehe davon aus dass
die länder keine mittel beantragen wenn
sie die ems zentren schließen wollen was
nicht vorgesehen ist somit also wir sind
ein gespräch und die impfzentren werden
offen bleiben und wer wir werden bunt
mäßig also und saugende finanzierung
beteiligen so nochmal ein digitales
frage von einem kollegen meier von dpa
wie sich an sie richtet herr lauterbach
sehen sie die gefahr dass die
legitimation eine allgemeine impfpflicht
schwindet wenn manche sagen dann
vielleicht auch in den nächsten monaten
gar keines mehr im weissen meer im
alltag
also die legitimation schwindet nicht
weil die legitimation ist ja dass wir
damit im herbst vor schweren verläufen
schützen wollen und in der bevölkerung
sicherstellen wollen dass es noch einmal
zu einer gefährdung und so
gesundheitlichen versorgung kommen kann
somit also ist der die
argumentation für die allgemeine
impfpflicht und auch die legitimation
und berührt hatte was ich verändern
könnte ist die motivation das so dahin
oder andere nicht mehr so motiviert ist
und da kann ich nur sagen dafür gibt es
hat uns in dem wir eine pflicht also
vereinbaren im deutschen bundestag denn
die motivationslage mal
erfordernisse sind bei einer
gesetzlichen pflicht
geringer als bei einer appellativen
umsetzung an dass ihm abhängt dann bin
ich wieder im saal bei frank fisch und
dann verbringen
natürlich gerne bei der motivation der
impfpflicht bleiben herr lauterbach es
kann ja auch sein dass die motivation im
bundestag leidet wie groß sehen sie die
gefahr dass die von ihnen favorisierte
eben nicht kommt und möglicherweise noch
nicht mal wie eine 50 jahre
ich kann nur sagen dass ich es für sehr
wichtig halte dass wir da zu einer
lösung kommen dem deutschen bundestag
ich möchte einfach im herbst nicht in
eine situation kommen wo man
zurückblickt und wir müssen wieder viele
schließen im gegensatz zu ländern um uns
herum weil wir die also große im flug
haben dass also finde ich sehr schade
dann wäre es auch ganz sicherlich so
dass diejenigen die jetzt sich schwer
tun uns zu helfen und zu unterstützen
für die allgemeine impfpflicht im
bundestag das werden dann die ersten die
beklagen wie konnte das denn passieren
und also daher muss man da wirklich ross
und reiter nennen wir brauchen wirklich
die unterstützung der abraten das eine
gewissensentscheidung
ich finde es falsch wenn da zum teil
wenn ich die diskussion jetzt verfolge
parteipolitische überlegungen eine rolle
spielen ich habe schon gehört also aus
den reihen also der also
befreundeten also fraktionen also das
ist jeder umgehe der ampel regierung
einen denkzettel zu verpassen das wäre
falsch wenn man das macht das wäre eine
das wäre ein missbrauch einer
gewissensentscheidung
von der für die bevölkerung im herbst
sehr viel abhängen wird einschließlich
unserer schüler und kinder für
parteipolitische zwecke ich kann einfach
nur hoffen dass das nicht passiert es
wäre schade und es wäre also ein
schlechter ausklang also dieser
schwierigen omikron welle weil dann
würden dann würden also ich sag mal
parteistrategen in kauf nehmen dass wir
im herbst wieder die bevölkerung
einschränken müssten
nur damit sie einen kurzfristigen
parteipolitischen geländegewinn
gearteten das ist nicht das kann nicht
richtig sein
nein also auf den gruppen anträgen sind
ja wie einnahmen auf der fdp also
abgeordnete zu sehen ich bringe in
erinnerung vor henning klar die auf dem
antrag mit zeichnet den ich selbst also
bevorzuge ich muss aber auch darauf
hinweisen dass der also antrag ab 50
endlich ab 50 von herrn ullmann dem
fdp-gesundheitspolitiker android man
dass das auch an also vornehmer antrag
ist der auch also den also den also
problemen gerecht wurde wir haben also
hier zwei gute anträge an beiden
anträgen sind auch maßgeblich fdp fdp
justiz und also sind als politiker
beteiligt von daher also eher mangelt
ist hier nicht also am enthusiasmus auch
der fdp für diese wichtige aufgabe
dann bin ich bin
herr lauterbach ich wollte sie noch mal
fragen sich vielleicht auch ihre beiden
experten kollegen die sie mitgebracht
haben es gab mal die zeit dieses zehn
prozent der fälle der infektionen führen
dann auch zu lankowitz symptomen gibt es
das schon erkenntnisse
ob sich diese zahl bestätigt hat und sie
als minister wird man da das
therapieangebot in deutschland deutlich
ausbauen müssen und wie kann es gelingen
ich vielleicht mal an djokovic
das verbindet übrigens also auch neben
anderen dingen herrn meyer hermann und
mich wenn man sehr früh mit longoria
auseinandergesetzt hat es das noch nicht
so also bekannt das thema gewesen ist
immunologische slongo wieder ein großes
problem dass es einfach also nicht zu
leugnen und das krankheitsbild ist
mittlerweile klar beschrieben worden es
gibt auch also mehr
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse zum also
eigentlich in pathogenese
und also die zehn prozent also kann ich
so nicht bestätigen es kommt auf die
schwere des verlaufs sein also wenn man
also die alle verlaufe heranziehen oder
auch mal mittelschwerer symptomatisch
verlassen und erweiterungsbau somit also
kann man den prozentualen anteil nicht
so gut beschreiben wie also das
notwendig wäre aber was man war es ist
es sind millionen und
auch in deutschland und es sind
langfristige verlaufen sind tatsächlich
langfristige verläufe die mit einer
erheblichen einschränkung der
lebensqualität einhergehen und für diese
also verlor verbrauchen wie ein
besonderes angebot der versorgung in
deutschland das haben wir im
koalitionsvertrag
beschlossen da ist ja vorgesehen dass
wir entsprechende versorgungsangebote
flächendeckend in deutschland aufbaut
und ich persönlich gehe davon aus so
traurig wie das ist aber dass also long
beach eine neue und bleibende und
weitverbreitete chronische erkrankungen
da schon sein wird und über uns die
arbeit lieben neue herrmann gestern von
eben erwähnt hat von gestern sagt dass
das problem in den vereinigten staaten
noch viel ausgeprägter ist noch viel
ausgeprägter weil dort viele leute auch
grunderkrankungen mitbringen die
lankowitz aus dem schwerer machen also
somit also grund zur entwarnung gibt es
überhaupt nicht
also ich kann vielleicht ergänzen dass
die zehn prozent die mal in
der diskussion waren mittelwert von
verschiedenen altersgruppen waren und
dieser basierte auf selbst berichteten
symptome
das heißt er kann schon überschätzung
auch eine unterschätzung sein wenn man
natürlich andere leute gar nicht
erwischt hat aber also das wird
natürlich dadurch etwas unsicher und
inzwischen gibt es aber wesentlich
sicherere studien die eben wirklich
klinische
kriterien herangezogen haben und ganz
konkrete
sekundäre syndrome geschrieben haben und
insofern
ist das dann nicht mehr selbst berichtet
sondern sehr viel besser basiert und die
prozentzahlen sind etwas runtergegangen
inzwischen die alters abhängigkeit
bleibt aber sie sind nicht so
untergegangen dass man deswegen
irgendwie entwarnung geben könnte ja
also wenn man aus den zehn prozent 5
prozent macht dann ist es jetzt kein
stück in struktureller unterschied und
die last ist eben extrem groß vor allem
sie ist extrem groß weil sie ja
kumulative kumulativ ist es wenn ja
immer mehr leute dadurch dass die
krankheitslast so lange bleibt
werden es immer mehr menschen die
darunter leiden also und das ist ein
problem was dessen wie herr werden
müssen ist es auch total klar dass es so
viele syndrome gibt es ist eine sehr
unterschiedliche syndrome die da
passieren weil der ac 2 rezeptor auf
extrem vielen organen im organismus
exprimiert wird und überall da wo der
aci zwei rezepte da ist kann das virus
einbringen und die zellen infizieren das
heißt es können extrem viele organe
davon direkt belastet werden
weil sich das ansprachen den letzten
punkt sehr viele organe können betroffen
sein
wie kann denn eine therapie aussehen
das ist das ja das ist das große problem
es gibt weder eine klare diagnose
aktuell noch gibt es eine therapie
sondern das ist eine schwierige
situation man muss es wahrscheinlich
fall basiert lösen und kann dafür keine
allgemeine therapie machen so ich würde
mit blick auf die zeitung eine digitale
frage aufrufen von dem kollegen klappt
nach vom handelsblatt wie lange sollen
schnelltests noch kostenlos bleiben also
die sogenannten bürger test und wie
sinnvoll sind diese noch mit blick auf
die teils aus laufenden maßnahmen
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt steht es nicht
zur debatte dass also die bürgerliste
kostenlosen bürger das auslaufen wir
sind ja noch also in der größenordnung
von also
rekordverdächtigen fallzahlen dieses
langsam etwas zurückgehen und daher
wollen wir hier nicht in einen blindflug
übergehen und wir haben ja gerade erste
test verordnung verändert die also die
anti gen test noch stärker in den
vordergrund stellen um die pcr test zu
priorisieren
somit also ist es zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
noch nicht abzusehen aber ich kann
soviel sagen im moment ist das nicht
geplant und das wäre auch im moment an
und vollkommen und verantwortliche
maßnahme weil wir einen rückfall
verhindern müssen wir müssen wirklich
also ich möchte noch mal darauf
hinweisen wir sind hier noch nicht also
in einer situation ich lese es immer
wieder friede um die unter gleich davon
kann keine rede sein sondern müssen sie
sehr vorsichtig sein einem rückfall
vermeiden und nochmal gar appell an die
ministerpräsidenten nicht über das
beschlossene hinaus zu lockern
dann danke ich ihnen allen für ihr
kommen vielen dank dass die uns rede und
antwort standen ich bitte verständnis um
das etwas steckte die hier vorne heute
aber wir haben eine anschluss picard
wünsche ihnen allen